comme je lai annoncé dans ma dernière
vidéo ce mini théorie va traiter de la
possibilité d'une future trilogie suite
à celle du 7 8 9 ou bien d'une pré
logique car énormément de choses
manquent de précision dans star wars 7
sans plus attendre commençons notre
analyse
si vous vous souvenez bien je vous ai
déjà parlé du fait que disney avait un
but précis avec star wars faire de
l'argent quelques spin off sont prévues
et la trilogie du 7 8 9 ne sera pas la
fin de la saga
évidemment disney a racheté plus de 8
milliards de dollars la franchise star
wars à george lucas et n'a fait que
quatre milliards de bénéfices avec star
wars 700 compte héros gwan il est
évident même certain que d'autres films
star wars feront leur apparition je ne
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte de
l'engouement que les films star wars
provoc c'est une saga vieille de plus de
trente ans et même quasiment 40 les
films touchent tous publics vieux comme
jeunes donc oui d'autres films star wars
naîtront mais il y aura-t-il une
nouvelle trilogie ou une prélogie et
bien pour commencer il est sûr à 100%
qu'il y aura au moins l'une des deux
pourquoi je vous dis ça car j'ai
l'honneur de vous affirmer que disney
est officiellement prévu un star wars 10
11 et 12 qui sortiront d'ici 2021
mais attention ce n'est pas parce qu'ils
l'ont annoncé qu'ils vont réellement le
faire
je m'explique disney a prévu de sortir
un film star wars chaque année vous
n'imaginez pas le travail énorme de
produire un film star wars ce ne sont
que des promesses
et ce n'est vraiment pas sûr qu'il
puisse réussir à les tenir est ce qui
nous intéresse c'est ce qu'il se
passerait dans cette nouvelle saga
je vais parler seulement de mon avis
personnel et rien d'autre d'après moi
ray fine écailles lorraine seront dans
star wars 10 11 et 12
nous les retrouverons vieux dans la
prochaine saga néanmoins je pense
sincèrement que ce ne sera défait star
wars fonctionne par trilogie et cela
m'étonnerait que le combat contre snow
dure plus de six épisodes on ne va pas
se le cacher plus longtemps la nouvelle
trilogie star wars pourrait se passer
sous deux formes que je vais vous
utilisez il est possible qu après le
combat contre ce nokia et lorraine
deviennent l'ennemi principal est qu'ils
soient beaucoup plus puissants vais là
où je veux en venir c'est que rennes est
pas quelqu un de très stable elle fuit
ses responsabilités elle a très peur et
reste très attaché à jack ou qui
contient les souvenirs de ses proches
qui l'ont abandonné là bas cette peur et
cet attachement peuvent mener ray au
côté obscur et devenir l'apprenti de kay
lorraine qui d'ailleurs pourrait avoir
un lien de parenté avec celle ci si elle
est la fille de luc
bien évidemment ce qui est probablement
le cas oui ce sera un calque de dark
vador accompagnant ce sidious énormément
de cas sont possibles mais c'est la
théorie qui me viendrait la plus en tête
si vous en avez n'hésitez pas à m'en
faire part dans les commentaires mais
qu'at il aurait une voix toujours le
côté lumineux et il se pourrait très
bien qu'il revienne du bon côté de la
force
il reste très indécis et star wars 7-8-9
vont rester dans une continuité de la
jeunesse de ce dernier je vois bien quel
lorraine revenir du bon côté marchant
sur les traces de son grand-père et
rejoindrait et fines qui formerait alors
le trio de l'époque de l'udc
anne et les ja avec une nouvelle menace
à contrer et possiblement une nouvelle
génération de jeddah est formé par ces
derniers suivant l'exemple de l'udc
passons maintenant à notre deuxième
partie est ce qu'une prélogie est
possible eh bien oui exactement c'est
tout à fait possible si nous regardons
le planning prévu par disney starwars 10
11 et 12 sont prévues cependant je vous
ai un peu mené en piège car qui nous dit
que la prochaine trilogie serait une
suite à star wars 7 8 et 9 c'est
peut-être une trilogie
suffit de voir les six premiers épisodes
où l'épisode 1 et le nouvel espoir avec
luke skywalker et la menace fantôme est
le quatrième film
cela serait même une logique imparable
que disney fasse ceci j'ai bien
conscience que star wars 8 et 9 ne sont
pas encore sorties etc énormément de
réponses à nos questions nous seront
apportés dans ses opus mais
malheureusement beaucoup de réponses ne
seront soit que survoler ou alors jamais
énoncés
car le besoin d'une trilogie se fera
ressentir ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que la rébellion de calais
lorraine avec la création des chevaliers
de rennes est un élément majeur que nous
devrions retrouver dans une trilogie la
naissance et la formation de caillots
lorraine l'abandon de ré l'enfance de
fines les conflits de année l'eia
l'isolément de l'udc qui d'ailleurs est
très confus et maladroits ont besoin de
justification
nous avons besoin de réponses sans
compter de nombreux petits détails mais
qui font les films comme comment caille
lorraine a récupéré le casque de dark
vador ou bien comme en masse kanata a
récupéré le sabre laser d'anakin
skywalker
pourquoi le faucon millénium s'est
retrouvée abandonnée sur jack où tant de
questions qui nous laisse sans réponse
et où une prélogie serait vraiment bien
accueilli davantage dans tout ceci et
que soit une prélogie soit une suite
sera prévu vous pouvez en être sûr et
certain
mais est ce que ce sera l'un ou l'autre
a vous de me dire dans les commentaires
en débattant gentiment merci à ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et partageront
la vidéo cet argot rock que le line up
soit avec nous
[Musique]